[Music]
one comic is better than the other
people think it's them we're smoking and
joking and having a blast two Comics two
cigars two Comics two cigars
yeah okay everybody Welcome uh to
another episode of
two comics
huh two cigars
oh camera shy no you're not uh today
we're doing we're doing a very special
uh episode of uh two Comics two cigars
we just came out we are gay men
always have been really
but now we're out together by the way
you said day it's I'm sorry I'm I gotta
check the microphones real quick yeah
why don't you check your [ __ ] ass for
my [ __ ] dude what we're back everybody uh
it's Robert Kelly and Joe list and we're
here filming uh two Comics two cigars
She Wrote This add V cuts
uh
that's our friend Lindsay she's got a
little acid tongue two two Comics juicy
guys at V cuts on Melrose in Hollywood
California we're Hollywood boys Melrose
Avenue Hollywood Nights did you uh did
you do what I told you to do
check your ass for my [ __ ] uh Joe this is
uh you can't you know YouTube when they
check the videos oh they checked the
first eight minutes and then we have
Cigar companies that want to promote
they're not going to want to you can't
okay do not do not and check your bum
for don't rhyme it with something else
semen
gum
okay here we go listen
here's the deal
um we're here we're here today we're
gonna be uh we're gonna be doing uh
podcast yeah we're doing it's it's in
Joe wanted to do it outside we have this
perfectly good Lounge inside with
comfortable chairs and we would have
shut the door and nobody would know now
Joe wants to do it outside the cars are
going by uh it's the busiest Street in
Hollywood and and people are walking up
to the gate because they see lights and
cameras and all that stuff I [ __ ] up
well that's a regular there's a regular
coming in to use the club okay well they
usually have folks here for the Laker
game so he'll be behind us but it wasn't
well
ventilated in there right now all right
well there's only two people me and you
I know but you know I [ __ ] up I I'm
just a
this is good the mics picked this up all
right so tonight we're gonna be I'm
first of all we're in Hollywood together
we're in Showbiz land together I know La
La Land they're called not Showbiz land
La La Land it's not a damn fool if you
say Showbiz land
Showbiz land
um we're gonna be smoking very two uh
two cigars that are attainable you know
I know we smoke a lot of crazy stuff on
here but we're gonna be smoking two
cigars that are actually attainable on
two Comics two cigars only two Comics
two sub guys so how'd the comics show up
it's just us I know no you stop trying
to change this I'm not trying to change
it you're trying to change me listen
this cigar right here is called the
illusion illusiano illusion a illusion a
yes uh eppernee
it's uh all Nick Nicaraguan Nicaragua
it's all Nicaraguan and uh it's a medium
body blend and it's a Levin robusto oh I
love it already I just got a big sniff
of it Kyle our boy Kyle Kyle though I
need him I don't know what left for me
is that what it says
robusto and uh MSG
MSG is not good for you don't eat that
MSRP is uh around 10 bucks for this
cigar 10 cigar that's not bad you get a
nice box of these it's around an hour
and 15 minutes if you if you treat it
right right so let's do let's dig into
it I gotta figure out this cutter this
is one of these Cutters that's too
shallow I don't like these shallow
that's called an idiot proof cutter so
the back is closed off the front so is
mine
[Music]
that's smart so you don't cut it too
much
it's called an idiot-proof cutter okay
all right it's fitting I don't like the
implication well they made it for you
Joe here we go all right
toes cut yours
oh geez yeah let's let's see I mean
you're afraid of homeless people but you
want to do this outside we're behind a
cage I feel like I'm at the zoo right
now
and we're the animals take it to the zoo
Rock that's an easier one you know that
line rocky two no Rocky one I don't
watch Rocky 2 I'm not an [ __ ] Rocky 2
is great I think I [ __ ] up the
idiot-proof thing look at that no you
did good that's fine you cut the top cap
off you're fine yeah you're a top cap
you're a bottom cap
but yeah we're here we're in Hollywood
Hollywood nights I love Hollywood you
don't love Hollywood I love it you
should grow to love I want you to grow
to love it okay this is why I don't not
love it I like it now because
um I don't live here and I come here to
do things when I lived here I had such
bad experiences so much rejection going
to you know casting agents meetings uh
auditions and never just getting
rejected rejected rejected having to
park my car over here walk through here
find some stupid Bungalow meet some lady
that didn't like me out of the gate and
then auditioned for a part I wasn't
going to get anyways because Toby
Maguire was gonna get Spider-Man
you went out for Spider-Man
wow I went out for the uh wrestling guy
who jipped him at the beginning
oh that ended up being uh uh Bruce
Campbell
um
oh he was the announcer guy he was
nobody but your buddy Norton got it yeah
that must have made you happy nobody
likes him I think he stinks and I don't
like him yeah that's a lot how do you
remember these lines the reason that
line I know because I worked at FYE For
Your Entertainment at the Hanover Mall
and it was one of the movies they had it
on repeat all day long I'm not a
Spider-Man fan okay but
you have Spider-Man's like body
thank you you're welcome I'm in pretty
good shape you're a shape I've been
doing a lot of push-ups and a lot of how
many push-ups can you do
I mean I'm not like a max out guy but I
mean if I had to straight you mean
straight through I'd do like 100 a day
Believe It or Not folks um to suck on it
right there is good well I like I like
things I like to hear
this is good yeah this is good right
here I could do probably straight
through really had to [ __ ] my life
they're gonna shoot my wife in the
[ __ ] okay can we 42 push-ups can we
go 15 minutes that's when they check
they check the first 15 minutes and then
they tell you if it's good what do you
want don't try to hold me back as an
artist I'm an artist you're right you're
an artist all right I will hold you back
snip a [ __ ] yes lick a small [ __ ]
um well Kyle
uh the man down here at V Cuts it's very
good Brendan Brent is that Brendan it's
Kyle I know I just wanted to see how
well you knew it oh yeah [ __ ]
um I called him Tyler last night
um I was like Tyler he goes no Kyle I
was like great listen he said that this
cigar
is the cigar that cigar makers like
interesting got people who when they ask
people am I am I correct people who make
cigars when they said hey what's the god
do you smoke other than your own they
said this one the illusion Louisiana
uh epernay
a Luciana Anthony and you know what
I'm loving it
it's it's light it's mild it's nice
it's got a little bit on the back of the
tongue
I got a little [ __ ] in the back of my
tongue I mean it's all come with you
what um how many episodes Have You Done
have you reviewed a bad cigar yet or
it's mostly a positivity show no I mean
look we're cigar lovers on this show but
we've had some you know we've had some
uh
I mean the cigar that he he brought from
back from Ecuador oh I went to Ecuador I
would light that on fire
yeah use that to light a good cigar I
hated that cigar oh I went to Ecuador
and I was the only one that go did you
did you this is how I hold mics that's
not we're not doing this set all right
okay
um did you say you were gonna go to
Ecuador because a lot of people said
they were going to Ecuador and only
Sarah talamat should I what yeah because
you guys have no responsibility my
question is did you say you were gonna
go I did not that's good so you're a
winner
because the other guy's a losers all
these people are like we're gonna be
there I take it back I said I might I'll
see if I can but I probably won't okay
yeah I have a son dude I'm not going to
Ecuador to visit a lonely Jew while he
walks through the jungles looking for
Turtles it's not happening okay I have a
son too I still win you don't have a son
I don't talk to him not that I talk to
you've killed all your babies Kyle's my
son Kyle's not your son no yeah the
woman was hot he got Sarah's genetics if
if he is your son he's a good-looking
young lab with good hair oh I have a
great hair I know my hair is the best
good hair
um so you're liking Hollywood a little
more now because you kind of you know
you let go a little bit you let go you
let God and it becomes a place that's
warm and nice I do like it it's just a
different vibe there's a lot of you need
a car
you you know you need to Uber everywhere
it costs a lot of money to be here
you know what it's weird to me that I
went to Austin Austin cost so much more
than La it's a fortune and they have
they're they have aggressive people in
the streets
and um I like Austin I love Austin but I
had some bad incidents there and why do
you always have incidents with god dude
I got a face I don't know what it is I
got a face something you have a
punchable face you have a muggable face
I don't know what it is I think I'm a
happy disposition I'm walking around
smiling like a little like a special
needs kid and people don't like it
dude I don't know what is I don't get
[ __ ] with
yeah
I don't know maybe they think you
actually are special needs though
because the glasses
you know what I mean they might be like
ah he's got his problems no I don't know
I don't I had it the other day Sarah and
I walk across the street I bump into our
friend Colin Quinn who's uh an idol a
hero a a dear friend I see him and you
just get a positive energy from Colin
you say that was that was meant to be I
was meant to see Colin yeah I say see
you later I walk four steps and there's
a guy I thought he recognized me
because he was looking at me and he was
saying I couldn't hear it and you know
I'm pretty
famous so the guy was like oh yeah it's
something something I go oh and I'm like
waving like a goof I'm like thank you I
appreciate it this year's material
YouTube and he goes uh you have
masculated [ __ ] you're never gonna get
[ __ ] laid you [ __ ] [ __ ] and I was
with my wife
who I've had sex with me yeah and then
he was like is he nodding her head he
was like yeah you [ __ ] [ __ ] he did
like the two-finger cigarette point he's
like you yeah [ __ ] yeah oh man and he
stopped and stood there and I went okay
punch him in the [ __ ] face break his
fingers grab his cigarette and snap it
in his [ __ ] flick it in his eye
because you can't see and then snap his
fingers and then [ __ ] your wife in front
of him oh why are you [ __ ] gonna go
who's a masculine now and grab his [ __ ]
and grab his balls while you're doing it
could you clean it up a little bit to
try to make money on YouTube Sorry
Apologize by the way I know how to make
money on YouTube now how do you do that
algorithm you need comments we got to
debate something and have people chime
in get the car let's do that first of
all I want to say this kill box is on
Louis ck.com go buy it right now go get
it this cigar right now I'm loving it
this is perfect we switched it we pulled
an audible at the last what was the
other the other one we're gonna smoke
was a Gaga NASA Leaf validationia from
Connecticut Nicaraguan blend Ecuadorian
Connecticut wrap what's it called
Agate what is it
agonosa Leaf valediction yes
um it was a little bigger but I'm glad
we switched it up yeah that's what she
said
um here's the thing
okay when you're you have to work on
your mean face
yeah and you got to get a different pair
of glasses these are Warby Parker put
these on oh this is the Andrew Dice Clay
collection just Andrew Dice okay
oh these are first of all they're heavy
my face can't carry these holy [ __ ] look
at me dude no one's gonna [ __ ] with you
you have those on
nobody's gonna [ __ ] with you I have to
keep my eyes closed with these on
because they're making my retinas
implode what is your prescription
how bad is your vision this is wild
oh my tits I can't even see Kyle
does Joe look better in these would you
would you [ __ ] with him in these yes if
you saw him oh like Ace Rothstein or
take him off put your other ones on I
asked you permission when the [ __ ] wait
that's the wrong line when you asked me
and I knew you were going to say yes but
when you asked me what did I say
hey you could be peshy I'll be uh Frosty
Halloween's coming up
all right put those in now or this face
who would you [ __ ] with
if you're a violent homeless person look
at those glasses
and these it's the glasses I don't think
it's the glass I think it's the glasses
if you got different glass you look
punchable you agree with this
yeah
you can you can say honestly I think
it's the tall I think it's something
tall does he not look like somebody with
those glasses that would go shh at a
library
I do MMA you raise your hand with the
teacher too yeah of course I raise my
hand I'm polite I care I care about
Society yeah but we're living in a
society you gotta dress like you take
you take m a net you MMA you know you
got to do grow one of those little
Russian beards
like just shave this grow this out and
no one will [ __ ] it maybe get a Tap Out
t-shirt oh no no it's not Vegas in 1997.
it's you you need to get you know you
get Gracie you know what you get is
[ __ ]
rid of bail reform and you get some of
these Kooks off the goddamn streets I
mean that I mean dude are the Liberals
in New York [ __ ] us
Giuliani for the piece of [ __ ] that he
was everybody hates him he cleaned New
York up
yeah disagree there's a debate sound off
sound off yeah no I mean I guess I don't
know I don't know what he did he might
have to tell you what he did you know
what he did he put police stations at
every problem area Washington Square
Park Mobile police station he put cops
in the Park 24 hours nobody did [ __ ]
they and you got arrested you went to
Bellevue or you went to Rikers when I
first went to New York in 2003 it was
like post 911 it was cops everywhere I
loved it yeah I was sucking them off
that was uh that was that was good
Giuliani man he had cops Giuliani had
cops everywhere but the Mobile police
stations oh my goodness were what uh
what really cleaned up New York yeah
well they got a they got rid of the
homeless too well now yeah I think I
think people will get arrested for
smashing people into the hammer they get
out a couple minutes later yeah it's no
good it's kind of sad well what else
happened though
Ronald Reagan you ever hear this guy
yeah he started
he started shutting down the uh State
Mental Hospital institutions right and
there was problems there obviously one
for the Cuckoo's Nest Great film 1975
Milos Foreman but he's got the Oscars
he's such a savant with that that's
right I have the capacity to remember
that [ __ ] I got an itch
you wonder why you get [ __ ] mugged I
got a mitch best actor director look
who's coming look who's coming up the
street oh boy who one of the great
comedic minds of all times agent yes Ari
shaffir in the house Ari shaffir in the
house did you bring his own camera
brought his own microphone yeah oh my
God you can be on Micah you cannot come
on camera why can I come on you know the
rules we made them up I know but no no
come into the jail cell that we're in
it's because he's super awesome right
there oh off camera all right you know
Kyle what that's Kyle what's up Kyle I
saw the trailer for your special today
oh thanks yeah it's out now I didn't say
it was good please go get uh did you get
that shirt from you buddy yeah vintage
right now go get uh super Juke get out
don't put your hands in there do not put
your [ __ ] hands in there I'll bite
your little fingers off uh it's called
um super Jewish it's called the big [ __ ]
the big dicks too by the way I've been
really spreading the word about your
huge [ __ ] and women are interested
really yeah I'm telling everyone in like
at the club and everything the man
they're like this are you serious I'm
like I'm serious Ari's got a big dick
yeah I am why did you get a big dick I'm
the spokesman for your piece I like it
yeah it's pretty good it's somebody his
dick is very similar to his ears and
face well that's what did I tell you
this my neighbor she told me that women
know how to tell if a man is a big dick
and it's from thumbs nose ears and she
was like I bet I know who has a big dick
this guy Ari hey look at your ears and I
could I confirmed I have regular your
mouse ears no I have regular ears yeah
I'll tell you who has little ears aren't
showing up on camera dude are you
kidding me yeah we're gonna turn the
light up
it is the I'll tell you this right now
it's all Nicaraguan um Nicaraguan
we get one for the big Jew here it's uh
medium bodied nice yeah and here's the
thing
this is this is the cigar that cigar
makers smoke
is that what it says in the Box no
that's what he that's what Kyle said he
said when you they were asking cigar Meg
is what they smoked they said this cigar
a lot of them said this one so we're
smoking this and it's ten dollars
you can get it check them over there sit
next to you no you cannot come on the
camera it's two Comics two cigars it's
not three Comics three cigars terrible
two Comics it's not terrible so much
better for the algo get his big he's
right there you don't need his big dink
face on here by the way Bill Burr is
under the table right now wouldn't let
him on
um get Ari's special
um it's called Uh Yeezy
it's uh I left a comment for the
algorithm I said I can't wait with a
party hat really I'm sure a bunch of
people are like [ __ ] you you [ __ ]
idiots
the comments were positive by the way I
couldn't believe it on what on Ari's
trailer oh the trailer's out trailer's
out I watched it today it's called Uh uh
what is it called it's called Jew Joe uh
here's what whenever I put up a video
myself a YouTube video Yeah of stand up
first day or two all positive then the
negative right then there's that goes to
the outside world and that's what the
[ __ ] is this I'm so unpopular mine's
just all popular it's all good which is
bad dawn of the only one's coming back
so you want you want some bad you want
some bait in there and then my my guy
I'm trying to catch up with your lover
he's like
he said responding to comments is good
so now I'm the guy that goes through and
I'm like thanks bro really thanks buddy
wow on the YouTube Yeah you got to do it
yeah he said anything mine's not on
YouTube mine's on Louis ck.com oh yeah
no comments here's what I do on comments
especially on other people's things
where people like oh this guy's [ __ ]
sucks it's not that I just go hey
actually we're not doing that anymore
oh I like that it's so good it's so Ari
just we'll just move on wait I'm gonna
do that no that's a nice thing to do so
now that we're all three of us here
which makes us get out uh okay it's cool
that was a cool shot oh that was a cool
shot I like that we're doing a full New
York podcast Ari's becoming a producer
did you notice that did you see him at J
special dude he was on point really I
mean on point his nose is he actually
came up to me goes listen uh keep the
talking down back out no talking during
the show and I was like okay I respected
it I was like good for you man well this
is what we've all been wanting is for
Ari to kind of move into a different
section of show business so on the other
side away from artists yeah with his
people and then he could help us I would
love to see Ari with a with a uh you
know industry pass the next Festival
yeah that'd be great do no shows you're
saying yeah because it's enough already
let me ask you this Ari should fear off
camera can we put like a cartoon on Yeah
well yeah right here
picture up this is all right let's go
what's up with the canceling every time
I get to the stand I'm excited to see
you kids I can't wait to go I can't wait
to see you a big hang tell them the real
issue big hang I want to be with you and
then they're like I already canceled
they replaced it with Boop and I'm like
oh Boop sucks he sucks
the sound edits I'm trying to [ __ ]
get my life in order
going away I gotta get everything ready
and everything ready there's so much
work that it's like you gotta be like
hey hey all right dude I respect it I
know I just released mine and it's hard
it's hard work you can't be everywhere
all the time and sometimes your
stand-ups gotta you know hey you're
gonna suffer yesterday like where are
you I'm like I I canceled the week why
are they not changing the website yeah
nice way to do that is to not put in in
the first place but yeah do that too
does it make you jealous jelly no that's
made me jealous it makes me annoyed why
because I wanna see you and be with you
I don't understand this just you just
cancel you commit this is wait a minute
you think I want to be here right now
you're too sensitive
you just said can I ask you a question
the people uh watching this are going to
actually want to get on there you can't
you please take your glass up put these
back on I love doing it inside look
because of [ __ ] Joe what no what does
that mean no he wanted to be out here
who's whose podcast is it mine are yours
ours it's too common two cigarettes oh
it's everybody's it's everybody if
you're two Comics you know you can do it
look at look at it now doesn't he look
cooler look yeah I mean tougher right
Andrew is gay
it's right there I mean would you
homeless guy would you [ __ ] with him now
no yeah all right take those off I have
to keep my eyes closed because if you
open your eyes your [ __ ] eyes break
all right now put your other ones on now
this is the guy you [ __ ] with right here
yeah this guy is Andrew lice clay
I liked it all right he's got lice he's
the kid I'm not doing this in in this
thing because Joe said let's do it
outside it's Aaron I know that's my
first thought too and then I realized
how cool would it be to do it in a cigar
lounge with the [ __ ] humidor behind
unbelievable
and and one of our favorite cigar
lounges V Cuts but we all come to the
best the best Hollywood we could have
been in there well it's moving in it's
better ventilated out here it's nice
there's nobody in there yeah but we're
in there it's three cigars four cigars
all pooling can you watch your cigar
I'll watch your [ __ ] tits bounce up
and down on my face
that's a good one right that's great
first of all he's implying that you're
riding him second of all he's implying
your fat yeah and two this third day
he's obsessed with you third of all
third of all two of us was it fat no fat
tits I just say tits yeah tits I would
have to have bouncing tits to do it yeah
you said fast and then fourth he made
him [ __ ] reiterate his own business
yeah that's just terrible this is great
New York in L.A don't you love when you
fly across the country to just hang out
with guys that live down the street it's
fun you ever yeah you ever go to like a
wedding or something he's like you guys
are just gonna hang out with all the
people you already know it's like yep
yeah yeah yep I don't want to meet
people now when your wedding I brought
you uh two boxes cigars
two I brought him two boxes of my father
about you judge I think you forgot to
give me the one box I got one box two of
them out
oh wait a minute I did keep one yeah it
was one wow I [ __ ] up two two weddings
two wedding stories
a you gave me I [ __ ] up I started
handing them out like Santa Claus you
did you're an ass because I was
celebrating yes but I didn't know that
people are [ __ ] [ __ ] when people
say they're gonna smoke a cigarette I
think they're gonna smoke a cigar nope
15 people lit it puff twice and just
throw it in the [ __ ] ground it was
like 800 of the cigars on the ground
yeah my bad disgusting by the way I
still you you know what it is it's our
sex box now the thigh highs the dildos
the condoms the lube it's all in there
in that box yeah that's right they also
have like Cedar
no the cedar smells like gum but yeah
that's our sex box so we think of you
every time we have sex you have a sex
box of course I have a sex draw
I have a Sex Dungeon
the other story yeah I almost missed my
own wedding because Bobby was too hot to
wait outside not sure it's a hundred
percent sure 100 not true 100 True
okay let's I'll give you 78 not true
that's crazy okay that's crazy first of
all you got he got married hot day
August you save money sorry
for Jew on YouTube right now it's all
about the savings Investments you can
make mostly it's not comedy it's just
various investing sponsored by Ezekiel
Bread
um so dude listen
okay hot we're hanging out not ready
you know I said let's go into the let's
go into the the hotel room where it's AC
it's at the so far not the room the
hallway the hallway no we're in the room
no you dude you're all oh okay fine the
most memorable day of my life I should
tell the story we were in the room and
then went to the hallway yes you were in
the room my dad wasn't Ari was yeah I
said let's wait in the hallway okay I'll
take you that see I can admit when I'm
wrong I said I'm happy to admit whatever
I haven't been wrong yet let's not go
outside and be sweaty for your wedding
yeah let's wait to the last minute I
remember that it's a wedding not a
sweating you were there hey
good job Joe thank you it's a wedding
not a sweating yeah it was a good joke
you don't want count it you don't want
to be sweaty for your wedding I wasn't
sweaty you don't want the guy I was
married
what is it cool and calm and Collective
you [ __ ] it up too all right you tried
Kamala damn it that's the president the
president yeah dude I saved you from
being sweaty that's why you weren't
sweaty okay can I tell the other half of
the story okay so you're in a hotel room
non-swap yes so now it's time to
remember being there yeah it's after
time we're inside it's me and Bobby and
Derek at this point my best man my best
pal let's say the wedding supposed to
start at three yeah something like that
I think it was yeah five maybe let's say
five because it was five it's like 509.
and I'm looking I swear to God and
people like is this and I'm looking
what's going on I can't see because I'm
at an angle cause I'm in front of the
vents so Bobby could cool down finally
I'm like I think we're supposed to be
out there I poke my head out the entire
higher wedding people perfect oh wait
there's like 150 people they're not
supposed to show up until they're seated
no that's incorrect where first no that
they seat then the groom then the brag
comes last no we're supposed to be there
everyone comes they were all waiting for
I don't know what it's supposed to be
but that's what it was and Sarah my
beautiful wife was like is he leaving me
oh and everyone was all upset the
wedding started late this is 100 sure
look me in the eye my wedding started
late only a few minutes late because
of Robert Patrick Kelly yeah because I
wanted you to be non-switty I wanted you
to be cool I wanted you to be as cool as
you could be head out there we do the
wedding you're fine I didn't want to
lose melting I didn't want you to look
like [ __ ]
excuse me for caring yeah speaking of
looking like [ __ ] why'd you put this on
0.5
what's 0.5 0.5 Zoom zoomed out you're a
tiny thing in the frame you said last
time I did it close up you said make
more room I had more room but not so
zooming in well there's a lot of room
maybe we should have ours is that better
should we get our end Ari cannot come in
Ari can see his producer now he's Ari
the Bruce he's not a comic anymore you
see that is that better you can zoom out
a little bit if you want pinch it out
is that better yeah you got it all right
Ari the producer but I thought you last
time I did it you said do not no don't
[ __ ] cut off your shoulder okay can
you not talk yeah I have a thing
I'm sorry I run L.A homeless it's like I
got riled up did you ever executive
produce a feature film
I did not oh I did
did you ever executive produce a
webisode for Comedy Central
no me neither
[Laughter]
yup but I did exactly repeat I've been
making some shorts have you guys ever
made a life in a vagina
uh look who's here another comedian no
get on go ahead again over here don't
get on film
what's up boy it's been forever another
great comedian welcome on camera if you
ask me is that good right there yeah I'm
happy to have you on camera another mic
I sure do yeah okay their sound is going
to be so much better than ours we're
using these little lavaliers what's
unfortunate is because Tommy's an
attractive man we would have one
attractive person on if you fail listen
you you are not attractive no I'm saying
Tommy would come in and then we'd have
one hand somebody died in the middle
Tommy looks like you like if they hired
somebody to play you in Hollywood they
would hire him the better looking you
that's a compliment to both of us if you
ask me what would happen What
this is dead air it's not dead air we're
good okay
um
first of all let's talk about this cigar
real quick we're kind of I love this
cigar I mean this cigar I I love ugh get
your hands out of the [ __ ] frame this
is what happened if somebody died in the
middle of it had to be rush to the
hospital in the middle of what two
comments two cigars popular episode who
do you think it would be most likely
him no way why would it be me if it was
an anxiety attack Joe if it was any
other kind of attack you guys are
talking about me from 2012 Murphy's
attack
if anybody came and Shook on those
grades you'd die you'd be like no here
I'm good I'd be like [ __ ] you you
[ __ ] loser introduce introduce uh
Tommy John again one of the best
comedians ever in my opinion
Cigar Aficionado I mean as far as comic
go cigar guy yeah and we're ruining his
Hangouts this is his privacy Club I just
came because I bombed so hard on my own
podcast with Joe I was worried he wasn't
my friend anymore so I needed to clear
the air how did you bomb on your show I
just think it's the least funny I've
ever been for two solid hours yeah it
wasn't easy but he pulled it off why
don't you stop it an hour
it was two separate episodes was the
worst part no it was fantastic it was
nice we had no plan check out check out
the Pod what's it called again it's
called the local news
I just learned that right now it's like
uh yeah just any news story that's it's
the news that won't make you sense
uh today we covered
um uh give us something to do right now
on the show I don't even remember it was
just like why you have a host co-host
Alex stone that finds the stories we
kind of nothing politics or pop culture
I just in my pockets once in a while
right somebody got arrested for bringing
a raccoon to a ball we did that story
too which I'm trying to find that gal
that's where are you trying to find the
the gal that brought the raccoon or the
bartender
bartender was behind was like hey well
she should be arrested for this let's
get these guys on camera no no you
brought a raccoon to a bar and then the
bartender called the cops hey yeah yeah
that's a good review of that can I say
something yeah I just thought of
something what two cameras four shots
four cigars that's a separate show it's
another show but yeah
if we stopped right now yeah and you
guys sat here that's still technically
two comments that was my question what
if somebody has an attack it has to be
carted off can someone else then jump in
well no one can cart them off because
they would be on camera
so what what are you saying though I'm
saying we could pause this yeah you guys
switch seats and then it would be two
Comics two cigars never been done still
keeping with the rules
I don't know about that though
well I think we should put Ari's stupid
face on at some point because the
algorithm
he's right there they know he's there I
want you to hold up a picture of me and
then we'll put that I'll do it I'll draw
the picture good oh this is knocking
this is gonna it's not gonna go put on
it I submitted I went I went to art
school in Boston yeah you went to fart
school well like fart school did you
guys hear fart school I wasn't sure if
you guys caught it I said fart School
fart School
so far it's good what about the haunted
house maybe I'll tell them about the
haunted house Tommy you this is your you
are a member of this place this is no
members it's just come and go as you
please I come here all the time been
coming here for uh over 12 years ago
they don't anymore they stopped that
code
it stopped a while ago pre-covered that
was um probably over 10 years ago they
did like a yeah but it's a big game
I'm actually yeah
pleasantly surprised at how good this
jarring is oh he's really doing it I
wasn't expecting it to be good and it's
pretty good with Bobby you just assume
it's gonna be subpar it's great
I'm just gonna Zoom it in further
further
that's very offensive but it is a decent
likeness that's pretty good that's
pretty good it's not bad I mean that's
great
sorry there's this uh haunted house that
I thought it might be fun to talk about
it wasn't fun on this other podcast I
did today I won't name names I wasn't
talking to him
um widely called are you ready you're
listening to this yeah I'm sorry I'm
about to watch the Lakers lose their
fourth straight to start the season it
could be better oh [ __ ] dream team
they have go ahead yeah did you see the
Yankees get swept wow widely called the
scariest haunted house in the entire
world McKamey Manor
is so horrifying that most people don't
even make it inside first you have to
look at a picture of Ari shaffir that's
not what it says in their shops in your
hand loser a loser [ __ ] stupid
amateur big dick Loser yeah big dick
[ __ ] loser it does say that first if
you pass the medical and psychological
screening as well as the background
check you then have to survive the two
hours it takes to go through the waiver
that covers all the Terrors that might
befall you including watching Ari's
stupid special when most people read
that they could be forced into getting a
tattoo or have their fingers shoved into
mouse traps what is getting a tattoo
what is this skank Fest or fingers put
in a mouse trap
they uh their fish they back out on the
spot and the words of one would be guess
I read it and quit blah blah blah but if
you do continue on proprietor Russ
mccamey is nice enough to let you select
two Horrors from the list of more than a
hundred that you're allowed to avoid wow
forced tattoos and needles are popular
picks finally if you actually make it in
size the scares are so disturbing that
most people last eight minutes before
using their safe word and tearfully
begging for it to stop wait what town is
this in I'm not sure I was thinking
German question we asked
you can't force somebody to get a tattoo
that's illegal you're forcing me to be
on a podcast right now
he did just want to hang out also
forever yeah I don't know I guess they
you sign a waiver it's like a two hours
of waivers that's not I love it that
level needles mouse traps tattoos I love
it you can't get a tattoo you Jewish
would you do that no but you could you
could say I don't get it I don't want a
tattoo but then like no you get what you
get
any Jews interesting has there ever been
a Jew that's been forced to get a tattoo
yeah Rich Voss let me think uh
anything out of a bed or something dude
you don't get it do you it's a joke stop
it's a joke it's not a joke if somebody
has a bet and for and you have to get a
tattoo you don't want that's not a joke
that's really serious or like let me
think what else yeah the Ari Ari what
like if like pure oh
Ari shaffir Jew it's on YouTube
are you are is your stuff on YouTube no
my oh sorry Thomas yeah yeah we have a
YouTube and a patreon let me try to
spell John again you can do it I mean
I've seen it up bunch of times can I try
first
okay j-o-n you're wrong see this is why
you should be on because I already just
made a really funny face yeah I can do
the funny face if you want this all
right like this
closer
j-o-h-n
a
can g i n yeah yeah yo we did it
interesting fact about Tommy johnagin I
think your given name is Tommy yeah yeah
he said he thinks because he doesn't
know if it's interesting but that is my
giveaway well I was gonna be bummed if I
gave that then you're like what it is no
it is why is that interesting his name's
Tommy no not a Thomas Thomas can I ask a
question you being uh special right now
on YouTube Jew
you being an expert at Get It Free yeah
get it right now
um watch it is the KKK really is still a
thing there then I think they've been
defanged
yeah I mean it's not about violence
anymore they're just about hanging out
yeah it's like it's like a uh like an
Italian-American club right or a French
Club pretty much yeah it's a white Club
it's just a club they're like fine
enough at the final it's fine we won't
do the violence can we just have our own
place Augusta National Golf Course right
I think I'm gonna push back just a
little
I think they're not great no that we
don't like them oh okay we're not saying
that I'm just saying they're not as big
metal lynching anymore you never hear
about it you never see look it with all
the cell phones you'd see a meeting
online you'd see it burning across you'd
see a bunch of hooded Guys Somewhere in
the woods wouldn't you I don't think
they're in my mom drove me out to the
woods to see hooded guys dancing around
a fire one time and we couldn't tell
from a distance if it was KKK or devil
worshipers but the KKK did have a rally
at My Town Square where in Southern
Illinois wow why did she do you know
what she made some questionable
decisions as a parent across the board
I've taken my kid to the Alamo to see a
scary movie but the war was over then oh
you didn't do it this was like we went
as when they were active yeah you were
at the height they could have made a
comeback at that time yeah it was just
like sat there debating on if they were
devil worshipers Megan Fox is drinks uh
machine gun Megan Fox you know her she
her and Machine Gun Kelly drink each
other's blood that's that's [ __ ]
she's a hack so I'm [ __ ] prank not
Brad Pitt Brad Pitt's Angelina Jolie and
Billy Bob yeah
what is that why would you drink
somebody's blood what is that supposed
to do possible reasons taste nutrition
craziness
I would take I would take two or six
sex I don't like food and sex never mind
[ __ ] blood and sex it's a pretty good
cigar this is a fantastic cigar ten
dollars
what are you smoking uh are we allowed
to he'll say a cigar no it's not that I
didn't join the the I'll grab one of
those next
what are you smoking I don't think you
can say it oh
the comics and two cigars if I can't
show him we can't talk about the other
cigar should we do the seat switch no
all right it was your idea we're almost
done sweet stitches are possible but
anyone who says they are possible you
might be bare from the channel so so
tread lightly with your comments yes I
agree I agree tread lightly yeah what's
what's the debate we can have for the
algorithm
Coke or Pepsi is
is Kanye right
what does the algorithm are you saying
the algorithm listens and then shoves it
into people's speeds more comments more
comments pushes it seems to be talking
about this I don't know what they're
saying but I guess people are interested
get it up there that's why a lot of
there's been several women comics
where comments have been like women
aren't funny this isn't funny because
women aren't funny and then women are
like [ __ ] you you massage this piece of
[ __ ] right and it gets like thousands of
comments and goes
so the key is to if it's like this is a
good joke this is a bad joke I like the
bit it's like not even I don't
understand how that works though so it
would be advantageous to pay someone
to do that if you were a company we
don't have to pay something we don't
really I mean I don't have to pay
anybody
yeah or just be mediocre
and then people like this sucks yeah
it's weird it's a weird time we live in
yes
but um all right so we're at the I think
we're at the end of this almost right
well you sucked that thing down like I
do I I suck a cigar dude I think I I
feel like I smoke pretty quick and
you're the lap man I'm a fast smoker
when I like something I really get into
it I really like with talking it's great
how do you like it Ari what he can't
tell I like it hard
what I don't know what we're doing
[Laughter]
don't you feel like we're gonna turn the
camera
[Music]
what's that we'll turn the cameras off
it'll be we'll be pissing our pants
laughing well this is it is fun that
when we last time when you're on my
porch when we did it and uh as soon as
to the cameras off like ah let's get
loose now like we finished the episode
let's smoke the rest of it and have a a
better time that's what happened I think
today the last time Joe was in town he
was uh at The Improv I watched the show
kills his head like I said he's murdered
it's like I was just in the audience was
a comic I bought a ticket I it just
wasn't gonna be on she was so fun to
watch as an audience member right and
then we hang out in my kitchen
and we're just slinging my killing him
with my wife it's just murder so I was
like we'll just do that on a podcast so
I make no plan and we come out and it's
just crickets in my backyard I think the
podcast was great this this is good
because people will go listen they're
like let me see let's see let's see yeah
it stinks that's like my friend local
news in high school my friend used to
have this thing he used to talk about
how small his dick was stop moving over
come closer I get a little nervous why
hey well people women became interested
let me see how small that is yeah
because he would confidently be like my
dick's tiny yeah it's a bummer because
he was a cool guy a handsome guy but
he'd be like I got I got a tiny dick it
sucks and everyone would be like huh my
dick if it's average like this isn't as
small at all this is fine and then
they'll be into it yes my dick has been
small for years sure now
it's actually big again let me feel it
did you think your dick was only the
part that was sticking out from under
your belly and now suddenly it's grown
well now that I lost the weight my dick
is back to what it was there's a number
there's like
an inch per certain amount of pounds 10
pounds 10 pounds is an inch or something
yeah what what yeah what I think it's
seven feet long if you gain 10 pounds
you lose a inch of if you lose 10 pounds
you gain an inch of dick because there's
a mathematical equation I don't know how
accurate it is yeah it doesn't sound
very accurate at all what about that guy
that lost 400 pounds he has a [ __ ]
huge [ __ ] he's just wondering like an
elephant but I there was a girl that I
had sex with back in the day believable
and
dude I've I banged a lot let's not let
we've seen the old Hutch yeah dude I bet
yeah
um and she was going around telling
people later she came back telling
people that I had a big [ __ ] great and I
was like this is when I was fat and I'm
like she's out of her mind I don't have
a big piece but now I'm like she was
with me when I was
thin so I think she was right I got a
nice piece well this is what we were
saying earlier I've been spreading the
word about Ari's [ __ ] but you're you
know in a relationship with a guy you've
never seen Harry's [ __ ] full though
you've always seen a full challenge
accepted
I'll get to work
what do you make of this Tommy I'm
listening I went camping with Ari and
and Bobby and Sarah my wife Bushcraft
party boys and one girl and then Ari
does the classic camping gag he comes
out fully nude yeah and then I was
telling the story just casually and then
several men were like
I showed your wife his dick yeah that's
nuts and then they're like what did you
do and I was like I was like ah get out
of here jeez and then they're like you
got you gotta like beat the [ __ ] out of
them and I was like Wow camping that's
why you need context yeah yeah there's a
lot there's a lot backstory to it how do
you feel about that I got another one
dick is a [ __ ] no who's mad as a fun
and a funny dick that's a dick in the
morning I mean yeah like did you like
when you turn was she drooling and
fingering herself I think if you grabbed
her by the ears it was like I'd probably
hit you you know stop stop yeah yeah and
then I'll text you I have to be like was
he showing it to her late at night while
you were asleep
he's doing shadow puppets through a tent
I call this one a worm all right
question I passed that one question two
yeah one time I was in Aruba with Aruba
Ray yeah I love a rubber Ray
in Aruba
I love Aruba I love it just a funny blog
yeah Aruba
um great gig Aruba Ray I've never done
it if you like Aruba it's the best
this is just revealing to me maybe I
shouldn't be saying this online oh Jesus
online or whatever the [ __ ] this is
I was with a rumor it was me Aruba Ray
and Sarah rubery was like hey do me a
favor put sunblock on my back
and then I said Sarah can do that now
most men are like I would rather put the
sunblock dude 100 but I don't want to
rub sunblock into a dude's back first of
all I guess it's just revealing my
girlfriend your wife's not going
anywhere yeah exactly I'm not worried
about that nobody's worried about my
wife it depends on who it is if Colin
Quinn okay
I don't know what Aruba Ray looks like
like if he's like a ripped dude yeah no
if only a wife I'd be like mad at you
but why do I that's what I was gonna say
like if you're having her do it because
it's gross for you make your wife do
something like that you do it it's like
picking up dog [ __ ] yeah you don't make
your wife do that yeah
has anybody volleyed the question around
about this Ray guy not being able to put
his own sunscreen on like what if you
weren't there he just gets burned it was
his back yeah oh you got the spray now
you can just spray it you don't use the
cream
the scream cream's a funny word did she
rub cream on his back she rubbed cream
on his back how slowly did she go that
homeless guy was right you are a cuck
Speedy but I I can't rub a rubber raised
back what are you in your mind well how
about this how about how about this I'll
put this to the fans how about saying no
no I did say no and I said sorry
just say no I'm not rubbing cream on
your [ __ ] back I think it's fine that
Sarah did it I don't have my son do it
I'm with you though I would have said no
I would have been like this is no and my
wife's not doing anything fly here to do
this it's too weak to say no how about
me would you rather Don rub some black
on my back or would you do it on your
back yeah not a problem for who if I for
Don or me to do it I don't care okay
yeah you're not a threat I got a nice
back Aruba Ray is a threat a ray would
array would might get a hard on
you know all right Godfrey let's it's
the I think it's the person yeah it
depends on the person Godfrey says
exactly I wouldn't I wouldn't I would I
would take the opportunity Godfrey's
ripped right that's what I mean yeah
what if someone was disgusted with like
a hairy back would then would you go to
your wife like no no don't do I'll I'll
eat this one oh I don't have a hairy
back what I do not have a hairy bag I
have the softest skin ever really oh I
have no hair ever on my body except near
my dick that's it and that died from
having a very funny guy fat honesty you
know your pubes die when you're fat did
you know that you die die aren't they
already dead
yeah fall out well they just they don't
have uh the blood's not getting down
there my pubes are coming back they
don't get blood in your Pew yeah you're
doing the follicles oh
you do what do you think they live on
but what about the summer clothes
instead of follicles explain it I
laughed all right
everybody left they're off camera
because Bobby's stupid but no it's me
and Ari big laugh it's the rules of the
show two Comics two cigars what are we
on how long 55 minutes to 39 seconds
we're gonna wrap this up all right what
do you think about this cigar now it's
the point where we rate the cigar we
rate the cigar we call this section uh
Joe list deserves had a [ __ ] thing
for it title but I don't remember the
the unboxing I don't know yeah
unrolling the rolling it out we gotta
rate it you got an idea for a name
rating it probably the best writer Among
Us is he really it probably is right
yeah Tim Joe the second he's a
professional writer right I like that
you put me third I appreciate that yeah
God bless you we both know there are
ahead of us
Joe is very good
um you know what's talking good about
Billy Bird was talking very good about
you today on the air no no in the car
just in a conversation damn it
um I we rate the cigars none one five or
a box what would you what would you uh
you know what would you get these I was
like for instance a super rare great
cigar you just find a box alone you're
like oh I'm buying that does price
factor into the rating can I ask
questions at this point I'm going to
tell you about this you know this is all
right yeah yeah price factors everything
does the price right The Taste the small
price does factor in yeah 100 where it's
like this and then you're going up five
hundred fifty dollars
and if you can get it or not these are
very attainable if you if you if you're
in Germany but you can get these right
Kyle
you can't
no you don't know if you can get these
in Germany he's talking about no here in
the states I can get them yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah these are stocked I think so
interesting interesting yeah price
should be part of it 10 cigar M for
right now that's the that's the sweet
spot because everything has gone up with
all the how many come in a box I need to
know that because that matters too
[Music]
lost city 10. the one you gave me ten
minutes ten I just bought the village
that's an exclusive box of ten even he
gave me a box of uh Lost Cities where'd
you find a box my special exactly right
I tracked them down that's amazing I had
to look out since I was at Dominica
Republic yeah I thought they couldn't
find them I told them when he was down
there they're very hard to get if you
can get him get him yeah he actually
gave me a box for my special kill box on
Louis ck.com
um I'll go first okay yep I haven't been
trying to get a word in for the last
couple minutes
wise it might fit better
is that what that means why are you
moving away from me
I just told you I didn't want to rub
you're getting out of camera you were
direct you were a producer two cameras
executive producer go ahead and writer
and star
um Fourth of July 4th of July Louis
ck.com this year's material free on
YouTube all right with the freak can we
stop mine's ten bucks it's one of these
cigars
um
well this is what I was gonna say this
is a nice now the only thing that would
hurt this from me is I like a bolder
cigar as a sober man I like a tobacco
Buzz a nice body full body this is
pretty mild too it's like how much space
do you have is this a medium space for a
[ __ ] it's a solid medium I think is
this a medium maybe I'm dead inside
because I smoked too early let's talk a
bunch of full then a medium
I mean I like this a lot I'm not
criticizing you know why because it's
not two hours
it's a perfect cigar where you're in
Hollywood and you're gonna smoke a
little one before can I make a point
box of those what I was gonna say though
is this is a nice cigar if you have
friends that aren't cigar guys but you
don't want to give them [ __ ] you want to
give them something nice but they can
smoke it the judge is too much for a lot
of people yes I disagree with that
because here's the deal when somebody
does want to smoke a cigar they want a
big they want to hold a cigar this is a
cigar smoker cigar oh [ __ ] this is a
cigar smoker cigar because you have to
kind of know it's not that big it's not
it's not that big when you're smoking I
like this kind of ring game was it like
a 50 48 no it's not a 50. that's not a
50. oh 15 50. of 50. I think it's a 50
this is not a 50. that's not a 50.
this
no I a hundred percent
this is not a 50 ring gauge but what do
you say it is higher lower I would say
it's lower
he's looking it up
oh yeah there's confidence at the very
least you shook his concert
yeah 50 is uh Kyle was you can't see
because this concept of the show is a
little silly but he was so confident and
he shattered
remember when I looked at I said it's 48
or 50. it is not a 50. I knew that Kyle
has to quit he literally has to leave
give us the keys take a hike that also
plays in because uh 48.50 is sweet spot
for me 54 is about as big as I'll go but
I think some of you guys like uh
60. what's the judge the judge is what
that's big
what's that that's a box press though
it's a little different what's that
Tatuaje that Brad likes yeah
it's not Brad it's Bert is it yep well
you're thinking of Bill Brad oh and
first of all that's my cigar yeah so
what what how big is that I think that
no that's that's got to be uh what's the
ring gauge on the the grand kohane you
know this is too fast it's a [ __ ]
it's a 60.
that's a cigar
that's cigars so so this is a 48. still
good down 48-52 yeah that's my I'd be
right in there I would say a 50 to a 60
I like but this is nice I like it this
is uh in between shows
uh morning cigar nice morning cigar
coffee in the woods yeah some moisture
still softened up too as you smoked it
yeah it does yeah so is your fat [ __ ]
you big dick Jew it's Jesus softens up
as you smoke it
um I'll give this a I'll buy five of
these and I'll give it to my family okay
I'm gonna buying a box of this is this
bad should I not be saying this sign
five is a company if you feel like oh no
no it's not like five of the cigars yeah
zero is the bad one zero say I would
never buy this again that's bad that's
bad that's the one he got from Ecuador
that garbage cigar he made me smoke is
garbage did he say he was coming to
Ecuador
he did not he was one of the people I
said I might I said I might try but I
probably not tell everybody tell
everybody the one person that came
journalists and no one else Sarah let me
breathe that out yeah but the one thing
I will say that I would I would smoke
anything at the v-cut Melrose yes before
a show at the Improv okay I'm gonna get
my rating on this can I
I give mine first because I am a comic
you're a producer uh I would say I'm
gonna go with five two I'd buy five of
these keep them in my humidor take them
with me are you keep them in your
humidor I keep my humor that's a good
place but I would keep them there and
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't travel
with them I'd take one with me when I
went on the road you know but I would go
through these quick I will go through
them quick I wouldn't be like I wouldn't
have them for years you know yeah Tom
yeah
I didn't have I I know I enjoy them
uh is Tom your nickname no nobody calls
me Tom I called you Tom's right there
I'll call you I'll answer to it I'm not
gonna be mad about it well I like to I'd
like to change you know you like my step
dad's name is Tom so it would be
confusing in my house well yeah you know
New England would like to give people
nicknames hey Bob K Hey fat dick you
want to know mine was Pub
no mine was
yeah kelski grammar no Kowski
it's cool it's cool
um you should do that at the end when we
say goodbye yeah um what are you going
to give it Tom me yeah sorry I I
interrupted you Tommy just from memory I
would be with you guys with the five
it's not something I'd smoke all the
time but they're consistently good yeah
I wouldn't sit on them for a while like
you were saying you'd smoke them because
though if they're medium they're gonna
yeah get them you're gonna lose a little
strength this would be my first cigar
second cigar of the day I'd smoke you
know what I mean yeah it wouldn't be my
Mains if I was smoking one cigar for the
day I would not be this also like if
we're all going camping and then like oh
[ __ ] let me stop in a cigar store you
guys go get the supplies I'll get a
cigar and you're like let me get five of
something yeah yes and it looks like
it's going right about an hour too for
you guys right around an hour yeah I'm
digging it I'd say five five so there
you go no I'm uh oh sorry I mean go
ahead I'm gonna get one of these this is
the one yeah if I'm in a store and I'm
like looking for a cigar I'm gonna
recognize this yeah
illusione yeah and I'm gonna go y'all
get one of those that was a good cigar
get one
yeah okay one so Ari's one the rest of
us are five
so let's go a medium loses punch it's
not it's just anything when you age it
loses strength not in a bad way it like
Smooths out again so if you sit on one
for uh it's not gonna happen in like a
week or two but if you sit on one in a
humidor part of the aging process is
they lose strength and they become
smoother yeah like when I when you get a
really heavy cigar you leave it in
humidor for a while yeah it will smoke
smoother later like I've smoked a cigar
out of the open the box smoke it
and then if you put in your humidor for
a couple months yeah and then smoke it
again it's a different cigar I have that
what's the Gloria Cubana is that it I
had some of those and they came out of
the box
like rough and borderline unsmokable
yeah and I kept them in my humidor for
two years yeah and it became one of the
best cigars I'd had I did that with a
couple something's rough just put it to
the side yeah let it go sit it don't
look at it and then go back that's what
I do with my wife's [ __ ] all right
well there you go two Comics two cigars
it's me and Joe two Comics two cigars
hey if you're a comic out there go ahead
no I love when you do it do it off hang
on one second please
oh that string has been on your finger
for about a half an hour it's [ __ ]
horrendous looks like my [ __ ] on a
Wednesday night
if you're I might do an impression
myself if you're a comic and you're with
a friend on the road and you want to
make one of these guys do your own two
common series all you need is two of the
same cigar and two Comics only two
Comics only do they have to have credits
can they they should probably do minimum
credits
a late night yeah I do two guys
premium blend people could skip it it's
okay we might do five a week uh two
Comics two cigars so go ahead and submit
them and [ __ ] send them in and we'll
put them up there you go it doesn't have
to be us it's not always Me and Bobby
it's sometimes it's usually not yeah
there you go so there you go we'll see
you guys next time on two Comics two
cigars
next time there'll be four of us on
camera at the same time why not never
gonna happen it's a good idea can you
please push stop
push stop hey I don't come with a stop
button I go